[Music]
why am i single that seems to be the
question everybody why is David so
single you know what I don't know why
don't you tell me because I'm a great
guy once last time at a girlfriend
that's a little personal question
she and I exactly didn't end on on good
terms manufactured never really told me
why we broke up
we were supposed to meet up at a
Starbucks I never seen her since then
you know what while we take this time to
go ahead and find it she probably won't
be too off-put by the cameras cuz she
has been in front of the cameras before
so just make sure that you kind of stay
hidden because if she knows that you're
you're filming her uh she will kill you
I don't want to talk to him
what Jesus day why am I here right now
this is ridiculous
looky looky who decided to stop by but
your damn attitude acting like a little
[ __ ] why don't you go well you've been
invading my privacy
you had your camera guys following me
around okay your privacy have y'all okay
okay you want to go then throw your
rights to my face first of all
you stop yelling at me you know I don't
know my ears are sensitive you already
know why I brought you here so go ahead
tell them tell my you broke up with me
because you don't know what I obviously
I don't because you over here getting
all attitude and stuff maybe I should
just go ahead and shave you bald go
ahead tell the camera why you broke up
with me because you done broke my heart
girl and I mean you don't know why yeah
of course I don't why would you be here
well you know what I'll let them know
once you get out of here it's my room
why I gotta leave what could just go
anything you should leave nothing change
tell me what you want
I don't hate David he's not a bad guy he
just doesn't understand the concept of
being a boyfriend for example the food
thing what you doing getting a french
fry
yeah I can see that but why why can I
get one because I asked you if you
wanted a box earlier you said no well I
change my mind my god yeah we having
this conversation again you know I don't
like to share my food and if you take
one french fry that means 50 in my book
so why would even you understand me at
all this is stupid is over get out what
you know how some boyfriend's have that
natural ability to step in and protect
their girlfriends
well David completely likes that like
the park incident
look eight I wanted you wrecked it after
we could ride zebras in the bush good
aspects that me and you okay
I only got two hot plates and one girl
she said I'll split it with you girl
[Applause]
she likes you to hand myself she's a
black belt in jujitsu did she tell you
that no she didn't did she
I don't need this [ __ ] right now you
know you can't be judging people as [ __ ]
how how what would you have done besides
um [ __ ] zebras in a bush put a snake
David
yesterday the girl come back on my own
perigee
haha did you know Damon because if you
stupid
[Music]